Bienvenue dans cette FAQ
du premier coup la rotation était maîtrisée soignée , contrôlée et je suis heureux cela fait un an
qu'on n'a pas fait une petite foire au questions et attendez je suis quand même le meilleur des hommes et je me dis attends mais
répondre aux questions des gens ça pourrait les aider à réussir leur vie alors il faut que je le fasse en vrai je trouve ça cool comme
format parce que c'est détente ça vous apprends des choses moi ça me fait kiffer de raconter des trucs que j'ai pas pu raconter dans
d'autres vidéos parce que le format ne s'y prêtait pas donc c'est parti allons y , FAQ numéro
(Numéro #3)
trouvez le numéro de la FAQ bonne chance
quelles sont les vidéos les plus agréables à tourner pour toi à part voyage et vidéos à plusieurs
clins d'oeil ,  ooh non mais tu me connais toi ! sinon est ce que tes proches te reproche parfois d'être très dévoué à youtube et donc peut-être
d'être moins présent
auprès d'eux ? alors déjà tricheuse, tu as posé deux questions et pas une mais bien joué, c'est passé pour les vidéos les plus agréables
à tourner, honnêtement, toutes les vidéos sont agréables à tourner , j'en ai pas certaines que je préfère à d'autres elles sont toutes cool par contre
il y en a que j'aime moins que d'autres il y en a deux précisément que j'ai en tête
étonnamment celle où j'ai essayé de
faire du bon dessin et celle des casses têtes et pourquoi j'ai moins aimé les tourner , même si au final je suis trop content de les avoir fait et
après tournage j'étais très heureux , c'est le  syndrome grands parents , quand tu es petit et que tes parents t' emmènes chez les grands-parents tu rales mais
une fois que tu y es t'es trop content , bah là c'est pareil , je sais que je suis mauvais en dessin et que les casse-tête me rendent fous
ben j'ai appréhendé avant de faire ça en vidéo puisque je savais que c'était source de souffrance pour moi mais au final tout s'est bien passé
et vous avez été
adorable et ça a été très bien accueilli donc j'étais très content et pour mes proches c'est une assez bonne question c'est vrai que je passe
bon après y'a plein de gens qui ne peuvent pas trop comprendre ça et que c'est totalement normal mais en vrai c'est que je passe
beaucoup beaucoup de temps à tafer et pour mes proches c'est vrai que je suis très très dévoué à youtube ils le savent mais ils savent
aussi que c'est ce qui me fait kiffer depuis bah depuis que je suis ado , ils comprennent vachement ça , il aimerait quand même qu'on se voit un petit
peu plus parfois , il est vrai ! Comme vous là qui avait pas appelé votre grand mère depuis trois semaines mais ils comprennent ils savent que c'est
ce qui m'anime depuis que je suis ado que j'ai toujours aimé faire ça que ça m'a beaucoup aidé à des périodes pas ouf de ma vie et
que maintenant bah c'est mon plaisir
absolu donc ils m'en veulent pas du tout , au contraire ils sont contents pour moi mais c'est vrai que je devrais plus les voir
Pourquoi tu ne cries plus dans tes titres de vidéos
c'est vrai ... QUI ECRIT CES ARTICLES ET POURQUOI ?!! REGARDEZ ATTENTIVEMENT CHAQUE IMAGE !! MAIS QUI EST LE PERE ?? C'est vrai j'ai arrêté d'écrire les titres en
majuscules parce que j'en avais un peu marre qu'on fasse tout ça , je trouve que Youtube perdait beaucoup en lisibilité à cause de ça et
surtout que bah c'était beaucoup plus violent visuellement de voir les trucs écrit en majuscules partout c'était très envahissant et ça me saoulait un
petit peu je me suis dit on va tout simplement arrêté mais il y a plein de gens
partout dans le monde qui l'ont fait avant moi et au delà de les écrire en minuscule maintenant j'écris des titres qui me font rire
qui n'ont aucun sens , j'aurais jamais osé faire ces titres là avant par peur de faire moins de vues et maintenant je m'en
fous un peu là dont je suis fier c'est celui par exemple la vidéo je dessine là j'apprends à dessiner et j'y arrive vite fait
c'est quoi ce titre ?
en fait ça me fait rire de faire des petits trous ,  c'est vraiment la stricte vérité où , c'est le putaclic mais inverse ça
me fait vraiment rire donc voila tu as dit dans plusieurs de tes vidéos que tu avais fait de la gymnastique tu pourrais nous faire
un ATR (Figure gymnastique)  juste pour le plaisir
clin d'oeil
il est vrai que j'ai fait trois ans de gymnastique quand j'étais petit alors j'étais pas l'éleve
préféré du prof mais pas loin
Pour vous montrez mes skills en gymnastique , je vous propose de lire et de répondre à la prochaine question en plein atr ... EN PLEINE ATR
Hello vas-tu sortir cache-cache 2 ? Ecoutez j'aurais ... (téléhone qui tombe) NON
écoutez j'aurais adoré mais la map ... (clé qui tombe) non mais attends en fait c'est un sketch là
qu'est-ce qui se passe j'aurais adoré le problème ... (clé a molette) oh mais pas ma bouteille d'eau quand même
je vous disais Honor qui sponsorisait la vidéo nous a un peu lâché je vous avoue donc on est a la recherche d'un autre
sponsor parce que elle coûte cher à produire mine de rien cette vidéo et au pire on la fera sans sponsors et du coup j'ai très mal répondu
parce que j'ai beaucoup de sang dans la tête et je suis en train de partir c'est fou , je suis passé pour un débile mais j'avoue je suis pas peu
fier de mes ATR , ton ressenti par rapport à ton évolution
personnelle sur youtube , ah bah je suis le meilleur , non mais je suis le meilleur quoi
c'est une question très sérieuse et très complexe et je n'ai même pas la réponse mais je pense que ce dont je suis le plus
content c'est de me faire kiffer plus que jamais ,  ça j'en suis vraiment content parce qu'il y a eu une longue période sur youtube où je
me forçais à faire des ATR pendant plusieurs secondes pour être drôle alors que j'avais pas du tout envie
*(rire)
heureusement les choses ont changé depuis plus rien n'est comme avant et maintenant c'est beaucoup plus tranquille , j'ai beaucoup moins de pression je me fais
beaucoup plus kiffer et aussi j'ai moins peur parce que bah je suis riche maintenant donc au pire ça se pète la gueule et puis
je peux finir ma vie (clin d'oeil) , quel plaisir . Est ce que vous y avez pensé à ça en faisant ta marque ?
évidemment , ben d'ailleurs les t-shirts devait ressembler à ça à la base ... d'ailleurs un petit clin d’œil à tout ceux qu'on fait une blague
incroyable là quand la marque est sortie qui ont dit : "eh si ils font un code promo ils vont l'appeler code lyoko " (Nom d'un dessin animé populaire)
voilà je trouve que c'était sous côté les gens ont trouver ça nul et bâchaient ceux qui faisaient cette blague  , moi je l'ai trouvé génial
alors force à vous !
Tu comptes refaire une rencontre avec tes abonnés partout en France et dans les pays francophones ?
alors tu fais sûrement référence à ce qui s'est passé pour les 10 millions d'abonnés le petit tour du monde là ... euh de francophonie c'était fou
INTENSE
incroyable quand j'y repense je suis ébahi et c'était déjà il y a 1 an putain ,  ça passe très vite , c'est effrayant , alors honnêtement je sais
pas si je referai un truc aussi rythmé que ça parce que c'était quand même vraiment épuisant physiquement
par contre oui c'est toujours un plaisir de vous rencontrer peu importe d'où vous venez et il est possible que
cette année je fasse des petits événements où je fais genre que trois dates à certains endroits
on dirait je parle de concerts mais pas du tout , mais j'ai pensé il y a pas longtemps à faire pourquoi pas un petit délire en suisse belgique et
pourquoi pas enchaîner sur le québec et j'adore les gens là-bas , l'endroit , TOUT . On verra mais c'est en tout cas c'est un truc ...
évidemment j'ai envie de le refaire , évidemment !
si tu avais pas été sur youtube ou plutôt si ta carrière s'arrêtait là brusquement
C'est impossible évidemment
N'en soit pas si sûr ça peut arriver très très vite
Qu'est ce que tu ferais ?
Alors du coup il ya re deux questions,  qu'est ce que je fais maintenant si ça s'arrête ou qu'est ce que j'aurais fait à l'époque si cela n'avait jamais marché ?
A l'époque j'aurais été vendeur chez Micromania
je vous jure c'est vrai , je voulais trop être baigné dans les jeux vidéo tout le temps et être entouré de jaquettes de jeux comme
ça et de renseigner les gens qui me posent des questions pour savoir quel est le meilleur jeu à offrir à leur neveu et
actuellement je pense que si youtube ça marche plus du tout
je suis en vacances pour le reste de ma vie vu que j'ai gagné assez d'argent
je pense que j'en ai aucune idée
vraiment aucune
le mieux serait que ça continue de marcher peut-être
Tu te sens mieux depuis que tu as diminué le rythme de vidéo par semaine ?
c'est vrai que j'avais dit
dans une vidéo , je sais plus à combien temps que j'allais diminuer le rythme de vidéos que je sortais et je l'ai fait on est quand même
passé de 3 à 4 vidéos par semaine à une tous les cinq-six jours , pas mal cette diminution , eh bien franchement ça m'a fait un bien
incroyable , vous imaginez même pas
c'est la meilleure décision que j'ai prise depuis que je suis sur youtube
d'ailleurs s'il y a bien un conseil que je peux donner à
tous les youtuber qui regarderait cette vidéo , c'est de faire pareil , peut être pas tout de suite mais au bout d'un moment si vous sentez que vous êtes
surmenés et que vous vous donnez trop , vous êtes fatigué , calmez-vous il y a aucun mal à ça les gens vont pas vous oublier vous allez peut-être
faire moins de vues c'est vrai mais bon c'est votre santé physique ou faire toujours autant de vue ... je pense que le choix , il est vite fait
Déjà je prends beaucoup plus de plaisir à tourner , à faire des vidéos et aussi à côté j'ai plus de temps pour trouver
des idées , des concepts , des trucs comme le hit de l'été faire des trucs comme la marque de vêtements et d'autres projets encore qui arriveront
pour certains dans encore un an , mais voilà ça me laisse le temps de travailler sur une
variété de choses qui sont très différentes les unes des autres et qui font que quand je bosse sur une chose , et bien quand je
me mets à bosser sur une autre j'ai beaucoup de plaisir parce que c'est très différent
donc voilà meilleure décision je suis trop content en plus vous l'avez totalement acceptée
génial j'ai pas mieux à dire .
Bon t'as percé dans le gaming dans la musique dans doublage
le film dont j'ai le rôle principal a fait tellement d'entrer (sarcasme)
dans la sape
Quel accueil incroyable
à quand le cinéma français je suis sûr que tu as eu
des propositions peux-tu en parler ?
une seule que j'ai refusé car je suis un piètre acteur pour le moment . C'est une très bonne question c'est vrai que les youtubeurs se
diversifie de plus en plus il y a cyprien qui a fait de la bd , il ya yvick qui a sorti un album
donc je comprends le fond de la question mais pour le cinéma
moi c'est pas du tout un truc qui me botte pour le moment , d'ailleurs je suis nul à chier en acting donc de base même
si je voulais je pouvais pas , mais j'ai eu une seule proposition de Fi... enfin de casting
c'est à dire que c'est pas " on me donner le rôle si je répondais oui " c'est si je répondais oui à leur casting et si
j'ai été bon ce qui n'est pas le cas , j'aurais peut-être été pris et c'était pour "all inclusive" la suite de camping et c'est  yvick
qui a eu le rôle et qui a fait
qui a joué là . Voilà pour la petite histoire
ça fait quoi d'être le premier youtuber français , je mets cette image pour que ma réponse
se démarque des autres
*(rire)
les stratégies sont innovantes et sont bonnes , ça s'est vraiment démarqué
j'ai reçu plein de messages quand j'ai doublé cyprien en nombre d'abonnés vraiment beaucoup de messages qu'ils disaient "bravo tu es premier"
"gg incroyable" etc ... et en fait , pour être franc avec vous ça m'a juste mis mal à l'aise c'est pas de la fausse modestie
c'est que ça m'a vraiment juste mis mal à l'aise de voir autant de gens me féliciter pour un truc qui est vraiment purement symbolique et
qui je trouve on glorifie beaucoup trop , ça vous a touché et moi aussi symboliquement c'est fou
sachant que la plupart d'entre vous me suivez depuis des années maintenant , c'est forcément touchant ça fait forcément quelque chose ça , c'est forcément signe du
temps qui passe mais à part ce petit sentiment là de nostalgie même que j'ai eus je vais pas
être trop content et ça va pas changer ma vie du tout donc c'est pour ça que ça fait rien de spécial du tout en
réalité , à part peut-être un peu plus de pression
ce qui n'est pas forcément très bien mais merci pour tous vos gentils messages et j'ai reçu des trucs vraiment trop bien écrit qui témoignait
d'un amour incroyable envers moi et j'ai été touché par ça et un peu mal à l'aise aussi parce que j'ai un peu le syndrome
du mec qui considèrent qu'ils méritent pas spécialement ce qui lui arrive parfois du coup c'était bizarre j'étais
j'étais entre
ah c'est touchant
mais est-ce que je le mérite ?
mais c'est quand même touchant
mais est ce que je le mérite vraiment ?
Je ne sais pas (rire)
Après que mirador et bye bye aient
explosé , la production de musique t' attire-t-elle  un peu plus ?
C'est une très bonne question , en vrai la production de musique ça m'a toujours
attiré ça m'a toujours fasciné mais même à l'époque avec Fezzo souvenez vous pour les vrais anciens on avait fait
"Journée d'un Geek et j'aime call of"
j'adorais trouver les paroles trouver des mélodies et c'était un truc qui était génial qui m'a toujours plu et avec bye bye et
mirador , bah là c'était carrément
incroyable de bosser avec des gens si fort
jordan il a une vraie connaissance dans les logiciels de musique et surtout il est vraiment bon quoi !
Il trouve vraiment des mélodies bien et tous les trucs catchy il est fort ! Kezah j'en parle même pas et du coup c'était vraiment hyper enrichissant et intéressant pour
moi c'est clair qu'il y aura d'autres musiques qui sortiront sur ma chaîne youtube là dans l'année c'est sûr et certain. Voilà après a voir de quoi
ça parlera , voir quel genre de musique ce sera
mais oui j'adore ça et c'est ce que je disais tout à l'heure c'est un truc très différent des vidéos youtube etc
donc quand je bosse là dessus c'est hyper épanouissant et cool pour moi et du coup quand derrière je me remets à faire des vidéos
comme là,  et ben c'est trop
épanouissant et cool aussi puisque ça fait longtemps que j'en ai pas fait bref je suis un putain de moulin à paroles dans ses FAQ c'est horrible
À quand la prochaine soirée du 28 ?
*(rire)
mec qui est allé à la soirée du 28 alors souvenez-vous ...
Soirée du 28 mais attends il y a une soirée il y a une soirée on prévient pas
attendez c'est cool je suis invité a une soirée le 28
on veut des news , est-ce que c'était bien ? est ce qu'on a raté quelque chose ?
comment c'était ? on veut savoir !
écouter si quelqu'un fait une soirée du 28 juillet
Bah dites le nous !
Tenez nous au courant putain et cette fois partager l'adresse
la dernière fois on était des milliers sur twitter à attendre l'adresse on l'a jamais reçue putain
de quoi est tu le plus fier dans ta carrière ???
De l'orthographe de mon pseudo que tu n'as pas respecté une seule seconde
J'ai une Shibette Meiko , Natsu serait-il intéressé ?
*(Musique d'amour)
elle est adorable .. oulà .. ouille .. mon coeur .
Natsu viens là viens bébé , viens me voir j'ai quelqu'un à te présenter
Viens là mon bébé
*(Musique d'amour)
Pas mal la go , je l'emmène direct à la cacanisette
Tu as retrouvé les identifiants du compte Instagram de Natsu ?
oui oui je les ai retrouvés ...
*Natsu : espèce de gros mytho va !
Sa va je t'ai trouvé une prétendante déjà toi !
Penses-tu faire une seconde version du hit de l'été ?
franchement grave je pense que je le referai en 2020 ... du coup ça va être une tradition chaque été on va faire ça
d'ailleurs j'en profite
Qui souhaitez-vous voir dans la prochaine édition ?
Qui voulez vous voir en invité ?
il y a trois personnes à trouver il faut bien entendu que deux parmi elles
aient des connaissances musicales
faites péter les pseudo
Est ce que tu comptes te faire une autre couleur de cheveux ?
écoutez j'ai pas besoin de la faire pour vous puissiez la juger , on va modifier la couleur des cheveux maintenant
et vous dites stop quand la couleur vous convient
*(Mario Kart Item Box Sound)
Ah oui d'accord !
Le peuple demande plus de THREADS (stp)
mais vous êtes devenus des
psychopathes avec les threads , vous êtes vraiment devenus fous
moi aussi j'adore ça les threads d'horreur , les threads reddit , les threads twitter ...
j'adore ça mais on ne peut pas faire que ça et on en fait déjà beaucoup
alors je sais pas qui est le chef de cette mutinerie là , qui est très à la mode depuis quelques temps
mais il va vite  devoir se calmer
Est ce que tu vas relire les messages privés sur Instagram ?
écoutez moi bien j'ai une anecdote folle à ce sujet
la vidéo là , où je vais dans les comptes insta
que j'ai adoré faire j'ai passé un merveilleux moment
mais elle a eu de lourdes conséquences
j'ai reçu plein de messages privés de youtuber qui était dégoûtés
Pourquoi ? maintenant quand tu ouvres instagram il y a ça
*(rire)
tu ne trouve plus un message privé d'une personne , c'est que des invitations dans des groupes
alors qu'avant il y avait des gens qui répondait à ta story
ou qui venait te contacter pour quelque chose et c'était cool y  avait des échanges One to One qui était trop bien
maintenant c'est que les invitations dans des groupes
et donc du coup les gens qui avaient l'habitude de répondre au message perso
et bah c'est horrible pour eux parce qu'ils voient plus les messages perso puisqu'ils sont noyés dans une mare
d'invitation dans des groupes . J'ai niqué les messages privés de tous les influenceurs de France
je suis désolé les amis
je ne peux plus rien faire , le mal est fait !
Peux-tu mettre fin à ta FAQ ?
*(Moment décisif)
Bon ok parce que c'est toi
c'est la fin de cette petite FAQ ça m'a fait plaisir , ça faisait très longtemps , il y a pas mal de choses à dire
il s'en est passé des choses en 1 an , mais on fera une autre vidéo pour revenir sur tout ça
voilà j'espère que ça a été ludique et cool
à regarder
et que ça aura donné envie à certains de faire des ATR allez y maintenant !
Pendant que je vous parle allez-y !
profitez bien de vos vacances , je vais dire ça à la fin de toutes les vidéos de juillet et août
c'est beau !
Et à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo où il y aura peut-être UN THREAD , ON VEUT DES THREADS (Bruit chelou de squeezie)
OH ! arrêtez  la mutinerie j'ai dit !
Et vu que je suis un gros forceur , je pars en ATR
McFly celui là , il est pour toi
*Natsu : Tu as vraiment l'air d'un boloss tu sais ?
Sous-titre par : Skywarp123456
Corrigé par : Carapus Poutata
N'hésitez pas a check mon twitter LinkedOn
Je poste des anectodes de sous-titrage